the fall of empire gentlemen is a
massive thing however and not easily
fought
it is dictated by a rising bureaucracy a
receding initiative
a freezing of caste a damning of
curiosity
a hundred other factors it has been
going on
as i have said for centuries and it's
too majestic
and massive a movement to stop hey guys
pete here
today i'm talking foundation i'm going
to explain isaac asimov's galactic
empire the fall of the empire is the
driving force behind the foundation
series which is a future history it's a
story that takes place tens of thousands
of years in the future
and is essentially a speculation on what
humanity might look like
at that time and it's such a weird
series of books in so many ways
for one thing it's just old the first
novel was released 70 years ago
and it's a fix up so the stories are
eight or nine years older than that
they were actually written during world
war ii also
asimov's writing style is the antithesis
of what you've been taught makes for
good literature
his works are primarily dialogue with no
strong interest in world building
or character development still there's
something about them that i really enjoy
and even though some of the concepts are
dated i still really like thinking about
the ideas that he put
forward to put it simply it's something
i enjoy but would not necessarily
recommend to other
people unless that i knew that they
already liked science fiction
and would be interested in how this was
influential in the development of the
genre
regardless if you read it or not if
you're here one of the things you've
probably heard about it
is that it pioneered ideas that series
like dune and star wars would use later
on that asimov was the first to go big
with this idea of the galactic empire
i suppose that's the case i mean this is
the one that people know about anyway
with all the pulp writers that were
working and churning stuff out before
him it's probably an idea that was out
there
but foundation is the one that everybody
knows about what makes the series
relatable
is also what makes it somewhat dated now
i said it was a future history
and essentially what he did was he took
the roman empire
and applied the same sort of thing on a
bigger scale across the whole galaxy
he got the idea after reading the
history of the decline and fall of the
roman empire
which was a late 18th century historical
series by edward gibbons
it's relatable in that they're doing
things that humans do
things that they've done historically
but it feels dated because
you would expect that over 20 000 years
humanity
society ideas of government you would
expect that they would evolve in some
way
that's something i'll come back to at
the end but now let's look at the things
we know about asimov's galactic empire
it's in our galaxy the milky way it's
made up of about 25 million planets
and it's mentioned that the population
was 500 quadrillion residents
early on in the empire for reference a
quadrillion
is one thousand trillions the empire was
founded at around the year 10
000 ce on our calendar when the main
story picks up
the empire has been around for nearly 12
000 years
so the year would be something like 21
000 and change on our calendar
the colonization was made possible by
hyperspace travel
and this is the thing that kind of makes
this whole idea
and every other galactic empire story
that came after it
somewhat inevitable once you start to
imagine a time when technology
that can create things that make faster
than light travel
possible then it's only a matter of time
until people start to colonize all the
different planets
at least the ones that have breathable
atmosphere
in foundations empire there's only
humans there's no intelligent
alien species all these humans came from
earth but by this point in their history
they don't remember that anymore
we hear characters talk about the origin
question
and it's generally accepted that all
humans must have
evolved on one planet but there's not a
general consensus of what that planet is
or what happened to it
the empire is ruled by one person the
emperor
and he runs things from the capital
planet of trantor
which i'll talk about in a minute
there's another group of people called
the spacers who left earth and aren't
involved with the empire
but they're really not important at this
point in the story
so basically humans from earth spread
out to everywhere that they could
populations continue to multiply because
everyone else is a member of the empire
there are galactic standards so
everybody speaks the same language
their standard galactic time and the
standard galactic
day obviously all these planets would
have different orbits
different night and day cycles but they
all have a 24-hour day
and an agreed-upon calendar since we're
already 12
000 years on there's really no mention
of how they made these planets
livable in the main foundation series
at this point they're all basically like
different versions of earth
i mentioned that this story was written
in the 1940s that was a time where there
was a lot of technological advances
because of the war there was a lot of
new things that were developed but not
really on the consumer end
so when asimov was writing these stories
the idea of computers
especially things like home computers
portable computers
they were still decades away there's
really no mention of computers in the
original trilogy
although decades later when he came back
to write the sequels
he did update the technology to include
computers and other things like that
the other technological thing that might
seem weird especially considering
asimov's other big series is about them
is that there aren't any robots in the
main trilogy towards the end of his
career he did introduce
ties between the foundation and robot
series
they do exist in the same continuity now
but there's really no robot
characters in the original foundation
trilogy that was originally written as
short stories
printed individually in astounding
magazine when those were collected
in the fix up novels he wrote one new
chapter to serve as an introduction
the first chapter you read in foundation
is the last thing he wrote at that time
and it does a great job of describing
the empire's capital planet of trantor
i'm gonna do a full breakdown of what
life on trantor is like
but as a preview i'll say that it is an
ecumenopolis
a city that covers the entire planet
it's located as close to the center of
the galaxy
as possible where conditions are still
ideal for human life
and it has a population of around 40
billion in the beginning of the
foundation trilogy
as far as what the galactic empire
citizenry looks like 21 000 years in the
future
according to asimov basically everybody
is
multiracial on my trailer breakdown i
had a lot of people complaining in the
comments about this looking like a woke
version
of foundation because of the gender
swaps and the fact that some of these
characters are played by actors of color
but in reality that's consistent with
the source material
or at the very least the author's
intention in the galactic empire
it seems the idea is that people are
basically different shades of brown
more than they're divided by the way
that we look at race now with whites
blacks
asians and so on i guess to wrap things
up
one big difference about asimov's empire
compared to some of the others that
followed in its footsteps
is that it's not necessarily an evil
empire it's really just one that has
evolved to the place where it's no
longer effective
in the blurb that i opened the video
with it's harry selden and he's
explaining some of these factors
a rising bureaucracy loss of initiative
lack of upward mobility a lessening of
curiosity
of exploration and the people who have
power holding on to it
to the extent that they begin to lose
the connection with the citizens
and therefore their usefulness comes
into question
so when it starts to fall they start to
lose control
over the planets that are in the
periphery the ones that are farthest
from the center
and as time goes on their ability to
hold on to those civilizations weakens
because this begins to happen out there
and most of the people who are really
powerful within the empire
structure are located towards the center
they would find it
very hard to believe that the empire was
falling at all
there's really no immediate effect on
their lives or the communities they live
in
so they're somewhat blind to what's
actually going on
i will cover more of this as i do the
next couple videos where i talk about
trantor
and get into the idea of psycho history
i want to do that separately i want to
look at it rather closely for a couple
of reasons
one it's interesting and also because on
reread that is the part that feels
most out of step of where we're at the
idea behind forming the foundation
it's pretty much rooted in a
technocratic ideal
which makes sense for the time obviously
at the end of world war ii
they were hoping things would be
different going forward
after the last 13 years or so after the
last year
especially it's been becoming more clear
that
an educated group of elites are probably
not going to save us
and that's not to say that the book is
no longer an interesting thought
experiment
most of what's interesting about it most
of the tension
comes from carrying the plan out
thinking about what that means
seeing how they do that and thinking
about how you might react if faced with
similar situations
so that's something that we'll look at
in future videos
for now this feels like a good place to
leave it if you have a passing interest
in the history of humanity in the
history of
empire how they come to an end i
certainly don't want to
discourage you from reading this series
if what you're hearing here sounds
interesting
i did provide links to the books in the
video description
if you're on the fence you can also find
it out there there's a bbc
version of this like a radio version
where they have actors
read different parts that's a pretty
good free introduction to the series
the one recommendation i would make and
i feel pretty strongly about this
is don't read the prequels first don't
read it in chronological order
without giving away spoilers i'll just
say that publication order
is far superior in this instance so let
me know what you think about this
empire how it stacks up against others
from popular sci-fi
franchises let me know if you have any
questions
what you're hoping to see in the apple
adaptation
and if you think that they'll be able to
pull it off please like this video if
you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already this is just the
beginning of the foundation
content i'm planning on making over the
summer thanks for watching i'll talk to
you soon